i if it's okay can i ask about how you
met your wife
phyllis yes um yeah we met a wee bit
back ago
um we were teenagers and we met at my
grandmother's house in her finished
basement it was my other
cousin's sweet 16 birthday party and she
came with a friend and it was
you know kind of infatuation and love at
first sight
she has a great warmth about her she's a
nurse practitioner and
doing a lot of work right now with uh
dealing with everything we're dealing
with the kovid she's um
you know one of the heroes of the family
that's for sure she's been on the front
lines
uh during the pandemic am i correct in
new york
yes yes i mean in in her line of work
which is often dealing with the families
of the patients that are so as well as
the patients themselves you know it's
that
that she bridges that gap of um
of helping manage those very difficult
decisions so it is um
it's hero work you know it really is
i love your story in your grandmother's
basement at a sweet 16
i can't escape it it's like oh my god i
gotta write this a little i gotta
do the david lynch version
[Laughter]
but that's uh that's not the truth i
wanna see the original
and the david lynch version and you have
two children together
your son daniel and your daughter julia
and she's an actress and even been on
broadway
what advice i know that you guys really
communicate with your kids what did you
guide her through i you know she hasn't
she's done she did the national tour of
flash dance uh the jennifer beale's role
it was a big thing
for her and got to go to new zealand and
it was awesome the the guidance i mean
it's tough you know you
grew up in it even more than i did i
always kind of kept
one foot in and one foot out living back
in in new york and
you know you want to nurture those
creative juices
and you don't want to thwart them it's
but do as i say not as i
do didn't work you know but she's super
talented
and i think fairly grounded i'd like to
say that about both my kids
and um you know my upbringing was that
way too so i was very fortunate
to navigate and nowadays i don't know
how you deal with
everyone with the camera is everyone
with a phone is a paparazzi i mean i
don't even
know that kind of pressure you know but
uh fortunately
you and i we came out okay i'm glad you
think so
i thought you were perfect then you are
perfect now
and everything in between as i said
before i
have been looking forward to this in
ways i can't even describe because you
really have been
this person that i've grown up with and
i just admire love do it for johnny
forever
and karate kid and everything and you do
exude such goodness um it's no wonder
your wife and you have that story and
you have
remained so full of grace
and this cobra kai is a lesson
to everyone in our industry
of how it can be done thank you for um
for the support for the uh giving it to
the show and
and just the big embrace we're getting
from everyone it's uh in this world
right now
it's pretty awesome well rightfully so
thank you ralph macchio kobrakai season
three is streaming on netflix now
[Music]
you